he has already fouled out Sacramento
would be really short of mix tiling
hesitation move our balance
here it is the song it's got to get rid
of it
kindly can he get it off for three in
the time yes don't look at it it'll
count and we'll go to over talker
turning that Martha
[Applause]
five seconds finally three step-back
three five ten to the second
the Grizzlies hoping he remembers his
long background in their tannin stands
but what a shot by Congo not believable
mine Conley with three triples in the
first half and converted four seconds
three seconds into the lane off-balance
[Applause]
Conley with three fires it up over Flex
nothing but that's a deep deuce
Grizzlies catch a break there he
certainly appeared to be hot he behind
the three-point line
[Applause]
behind this fan shape looks at this box
to 40s for selling secretaries
[Music]
does it look like that food spider
it doesn't happen often but Grizzlies in
transition using LaMarcus Aldridge as a
take that time Laird gets hung up on it
and then left hander my Tommy a great
bit of celebrating with Tony Allen on
the side binding that's right armor feat
in Memphis
[Applause]
Mike Conley typically loves to finish
with his right hand but that's time look
beautiful roll off the glass with the
left as he goes down beautiful jump stop
around Higa dalla avoids the block
beautiful play there right in front of
us Mike Comrie she watch this replay
again like Heather tip you off to
earlier not only does he at 25 points my
go to 10 assists and how about 6
rebounds get believe it that one it took
that step back in as a 2 or 3 John Goble
says it's to not a three against
Brooklyn both Memphis victories
[Applause]
my colleague watch the dribbling ability
to hesitation oh no shot finish up and
under beautiful pork shock box for the
Grizzlies down to five Conley on a curl
Singler on his hip in the lane of school
to run their offensive set nice find
underneath to Jamaica green beautiful
fine by Mike Riley
great wraparound pass there by Mike
Conley will get it back on 24 second
possession and compan a knock away as
Vince Carter collides with McConnell
Conley with a dunk well it goes up when
you see here Mike Conley
get up showing his buddies out there on
the floor and that is the great tale
long jumper Mike Conley former Ohio
State Buckeyes you cannot catch your own
shot Conley wide open to the cup lays it
up and lays it in
we characteristic there defensively
whether Charlotte Hornets team full
screens for Conley
I think the degree of difficulty no
matter what country the judge is from
that's a lot right it's got a bid ten
that's an amazing finish it's all
against Laverne lock down a tube down to
one Conley goes
three-ball by Mike Conley at the first
half Horne
rezzie's had been empty from downtown in
the second quarter until that make by
Conley
[Applause]
performance after just seven Monday
against Denver trying to draw sixth on
AC that is this tremendous body control
toggling a 3-2 feedback of a second
three of four from beyond the arc
Grizzly's rack up 35 in the second the
quarters that get the best of all of the
work of a solution they don't go sit a
spoon for him toss is over against Kali
but he knocks it free and it's Rubio
tries to disrupt by the Richelieu neck
you cannot get all the way to the rim
so here Connolly with the hesitation who
won't call it all drizzle on the floor
and then is able to split the defenders
and finish at the rim that different can
get here Conley's most calls going to
give him some room
Connelly in three
[Applause]
McCollum just continues to retreat but
Mike Conley says all I need is a little
bit of space to make the twine tickling
best quest - guide in those games in the
league is Andrew Harrison here's Conley
for three bingo another great place to
shoot five to shoot
[Applause]
a lease which screamed back on time with
Thompson's Angus old Ty Lee pulls back
jumpers up and it's good
totally ties the game with 7.4 remaining
and everybody out of my way
stops on a dime gives them 9 cents
change elevates beautiful beautiful
place Ryan Anderson
hardly
[Applause]
in the Chrissie's 9 of 25 from distance
the look ahead in Tony Allen pretty play
shot clock down to 5 time legal hostage
got it back through short John clock to
got to go with it sends it and scores it
a long two for Mike Conley to tie the
game at 8 after that possession
gets it to Conley katli splits through
i fathers the defense go
under the defender and finishes her off
screen by two Michael three seconds Nets
whenever foul to give
fadeaway Conley it's in for two-tenths
of a second to call the Grizzlies were
there to move it to that double digit
range Kylie
[Applause]
tell me what do I have to do to get that
same call but I didn't get the an I
didn't get the three free-throws earlier
but not only was my colleague getting
this far though he is making the shout
out for the contact for timely about a
play maker off the high screen and roll
Danny Green one of the better defenders
in the league a little bit of a bump the
concentration to take that hit and put
it on the rim walked by Leonard nine
seconds left Grizzlies down to sit up
[Applause]
but a little bit of misdirection from
Daniels out front you get the switch to
Tony Parker his ability to finish with
both hands gets Tony moving all the way
and delivers a dagger Tony actually does
a pretty good job staying in front
trying to stay in his space
spread the floor for Conley drives the
middle of the lane hesitation Lube off
the high class Indian oh my what I shot
by Mike Conley in this shot here partner
it hits at the top load a glass lesson
on the top of the backboard turn play as
long as it doesn't go over time like two
seconds or three good if it goes it does
with five tenths of a second Connelly
shoots the Grizzlies back into the lead
at 74 to 71
family launching a three that's his
third three tonight Utah does not have a
foul to give Jared the screen they got
the switch Conley for three ring it up
you're excited that you got the win
what's your concentration level had to
step up over the win this type of day
Todd Lee makes it 95 89 shot clock is
off potentially temple misses go win a
game scoring fewer than 100 points 792
gotta put us down with it one three to
shoot
Conley step-back three seconds finally
across midcourt trying to get a
desperation either way and faked it in
ruling on the floor it is a good basket
Mike oddly from three Conley in traffic
double clutches and just get it away in
time reason why a sign of their feelings
of these guys torch you on your end
do it for you piling over 80 Wow big
shot by Connelly over a big man
Indiana timely retreats for three the
floor general has forced everyone to
pick up their energy timely against
various owners to take them off the
bounce off the high clashing in
got it back forces it up
holy cow what a shot from Conley plays
with his late to see here at Connolly
mr. fourth-quarter foot his Grizzlies
team has great defense by Eric Blessed
just better offense by Congress
9:00 in the quarter and that the biggest
bucket is a frame can help deck
Red Cross Connelly shot clock down to
twos got to put up a runner banks it in
buzzer which in earlier Sunday afternoon
in Minnesota Conley comes through with
it
shot clock down to two gotta live at 308
come on
Grizzly's just to beat the clock Kylee
however splashes this triple his first
of the night hustling it's Alan
1:17 with 9.9 remaining which in the Lao
Mike Conley to play one-on-one with
Jared island this plays right into the
Grizzlies hands the only thing if you're
a Grizzlies fans you might say Mike
Conley hold the basketball for one more
second seeking but you needed to score
and if he doesn't make this shot here
you need the opportunity to get an
offensive rebound beautiful move two
seconds to go to the replay Center to
confirm but high school here coming soon
I know the holidays are upon us
Johnson against piling the rejection out
of bounds that will stay with Miami and
rivers tries to make em language motor
not there rebounds through the hands of
capela picked up by Conley a look ahead
temple leaves it up and lays in
brizzy's attacking in the paint not
survive in today's NBA taking six three
two games Tim Russert playing against a
team of this caliber is Charlie gets
another three-point play opportunity
here and to slow the game down minimize
possessions Conley little step-back
three yes right at the end of the first
corner Mike Conley threes at three gets
it off in time takes us to the end of
the first you got me
Conley for three beg apart one too long
too long to the car Lane says let's
review it the lawn right crosses over
Conley
[Applause]
his second triple of the game he's got
20 long she has shot clock running down
but getting the size come on right love
tits go away from the screen it they
want to see on the top pinpoint Pass
Grizzlies have the size advantage right
now see if they can continue to dominate
the board Conley attacks floats it up
and in Grizzlies have the lead 100 to
9999 Grizzlies with the lead Conley
going class
McGee in the air spins and has it
blocked by McGee
Tommy's gotta let it by to beat the shot
pocket it's the three
unless is my colleague to 34.2 connelly
met at half-court Conley pulls up to
because yet guys
Conley with the exclamation point
the Grizzles great move here by connelly
to push the basketball really what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content